nun momentan sehe ich es noch nicht dass
die Unterstützung unserer Partner in
irgendeiner Form
abnimmt wir haben tatsächlich
Zusicherung auf allen Ebenen erhalten
dass die Unterstützung für die Ukraine
fortgeführt werden wird unsere Partner
haben die Kapazitäten um diese
Unterstützung auch zur Verfügung zuellen
natürlich wird mit der Entwicklung der
Situation
imOsten dar nicht weiter eskalieren wird
dass da dann aber auch die Umstände sich
ändern können
denn je länger dieser Krieg andauut
desto mehr Ressourcen wird in Anspruch
nehmen aber ich glaube dass die
wichtigsten Hauptstädte ein ganz klares
Verständnis dafür haben was auf dem
Spiel steht sowohl in der Ukraine als
auch im Nahen Osten und dass es da um
sehr viel mehr geht als nur um die
Sicherheit in diesen Teilen der Welt und
dass es deshalb notwendig ist
Unterstützung aufrecht zuerhalten damit
ein gerechter und auch nachhaltiger
Frieden gesichert werden kann